NARRATOR: This guy went
over 600 miles per hour,
earning himself the title
of fastest man alive.
But did he survive?
John Paul Stapp was a
physician in the Air Force
who was fascinated by speed
and the effects of g-force
on the human body.
g-force is the measurement of
acceleration due to gravity.
On earth, gravity
causes us to accelerate
towards the center of the planet
at 32 feet per second squared,
which is a force of 1g.
But if you hop onto a roller
coaster or into an airplane,
the increased
acceleration will cause
more g-force and perceived
weight on your body.
So how much g-force is safe?
In the 1940s it was assumed that
pilots could only withstand up
to 18 g's.
But Stapp believed humans could
withstand more, much more.
To test his theory,
Stapp built a rocket sled
that propelled down a track
at hundreds of miles an hour.
At first he used dummies,
but eventually he
tested it on himself.
During his last run, Stapp
hit 632 miles an hour
in five seconds, and stopped
in just over one second,
subjecting himself to a whopping
46.2 g's, and making his body
weight around 7,700 pounds
for that brief moment.
Stapp's trials led
to some injuries
like broken ribs, a
hernia, a shattered wrist,
hemorrhages in the eye,
a fractured tailbone,
and temporary blindness.
But Stapp survived.
And he later went on to
work with NASA as well
as on some of the first
tests for airbags in cars.